hey guys it's Justine and WWDC is going
to be here before we know it WWDC is the
worldwide developers conference that
Apple has that basically sets us up for
the next year what we can expect and
kind of giving developers a heads up of
like hey this is what we've got what can
you guys do with this so we're here on
Mac Rumors they've got a little Roundup
here of what we can expect from WWDC
2023. on June 5th through the 9th with
select developers and students who are
invited to the special keynote Monday
June 5th the first time that I went to
WWDC probably one of the happiest days
of my life I mean definitely top three
for sure because as a child that was
something that I had always dreamed of
going to so getting to really experience
that for the first time ever was just
it really was a dream come true the
first thing that we have
we have hardware and now announcements
WWDC is mostly geared towards software
and developing for Hardware but they
have been known in the past to announce
some hardware and I do feel like this
might be finally the year that they make
mention of the long-awaited AR VR
headset I mean this seems pretty
confident they're saying Apple will show
off the long rumored headset according
to rumors of course so they have a
little room a Roundup of some of the
things that we can potentially expect to
see in this device both augmented and
virtual reality capabilities with an
option to switch modes with a digital
Crown like control knob probably like
the crown on the Apple watch an external
battery pack worn at the waist I mean
okay I'll do it I've I've done stranger
things like you know live stream my life
for six months straight wearing a
backpack with a computer in it and a
webcam on my head
lightweight comfortable design with
Apple watch like band and mesh against
the face option for prescription lenses
4K micro OLED displays powerful Apple
silicon chips the same chips in the Mac
I don't know if it's going to be an M1
M2 who knows we I mean I would imagine
it's going to be some sort of M chip
maybe they have like an MVR an Nar
that's specific to this device I don't
know they've got a new operating system
xros so it's going to have a dedicated
App Store unique FaceTime experiences
and the option to run iPhone iPad apps
gesture based control method with no
physical controller a dozen plus cameras
that can read facial expressions detect
body movements and map surrounding areas
it'll also have for authentication Iris
scanning which kind of makes sense
because you're not going to want
somebody to be picking up your device if
it has all of your information on it
there have been so many renders over the
years here are a few of them I mean they
range from wow this is really cool
looking to hmm what were you thinking
I'm a huge fan of augmented reality so
I'm excited to see what Apple does does
with this the Mac Pro this is also
something that has been long awaited we
are due for a new Mac Pro especially one
that has the updated end chips in it so
it looks like Apple's planning to
introduce an updated version of the Mac
Pro here judging by the rumors a lot of
the renders that I've seen are basically
just smaller versions of the current
large Mac Pro so I think that would be
kind of cool having a smaller version of
that because it really is a good look
but it is quite large 15-inch MacBook
Air for being a software focused event
it sure seems like there's a lot of
Hardware that's being rumored to be
announced
software announcements here we are iOS
17 iPad OS 17 Mac OS 14 TV OS 17 watch
OS 10. wow I
feel very old now iOS 17 is expected to
feature several quality of life
improvements what does that mean rather
than a single major headlining feature
okay they're saying that this update
isn't going to be as big as some
previous ones there have been rumors of
side loading apps more specifically in
the UK because of regulatory changes so
I'm not sure if that's going to be
something that they're going to be also
bringing to the US but I do feel like
there are going to be a lot of App Store
changes so iOS 17 will probably take
into account all of those changes either
for us the UK or who knows which is the
future of the App Store look like other
iOS 17 editions will include AR VR
headset integration and upgraded carplay
yes love that even though my Tesla
doesn't have carplay and I think about
how much I hate that every day because I
wish that it did oh my gosh here's a
whole iOS 17 most requested features
what do you guys think what are some of
the biggest features that you'd like to
see in iOS 17. I honestly can't even
think of anything right now I'll get
back to you on that one well thank you
guys for watching if you guys want to
watch some more videos I'll put some
here on the end screen don't forget to
like comment and subscribe and be sure
to hit the Bell to be notified when I
post new videos I am so excited for
apple season I'll see you guys in the
next one bye